la santé des étudiants à la loupe avec
le lancement d'une enquête sans
précédent ishare c'est son nom se veut
la plus grande cohorte et kort
épidémiologique jamais réalisé 36 mille
étudiants concernés bonsoir donc à
didier guillemot professeur
d'épidémiologie et de santé publique
expliquez nous à quoi va servir cette
enquête sans précédent bonsoir
et bien c'est une enquête qui va servir
à plusieurs choses
tout d'abord la question de la santé des
étudiants au sens par exemple de leurs
difficultés d'accès aux soins au sens de
la manière dont ils s'occupent de leur
santé alors fin bien sûr les étudiants
on peut les ponts c'est pas trop malade
et ça peut apparaître être un
la préoccupation relativement
anecdotique
pour autant ils ont des problèmes ils
ont des questions ils ont des accès aux
soins par exemple pour la santé dentaire
qui est on le sait plus ou moins bien
mais on le pressent relativement
difficile ancien remet absolument parce
que parce que parfois aussi ils ne
savent pas comment faire avec les
mutuelles c'est compliqué et les
remboursements enfin il ya les papiers
voilà donc c'est déjà un premier acte
c'est à dire d'essayer de mieux
comprendre quelles sont les difficultés
d'accès aux soins
ils peuvent être aussi dans une certaine
relative précarité économique dont c'est
un axe sacchi être santé publique et
puis on va s'intéresser à d'autres
questions à s'intéresser à la santé
mentale alors la santé mentale sa dot à
dire que d'étudiants ont beaucoup de
problèmes de santé mentale mais par
contre ce qu'on pressent aussi c'est
qu'ils ont du stress et que ce stress de
ressentie et peut avoir des effets sur
la manière dont ils réussissent l'examen
dont il
les commandes le jeune et puis il ya des
questions plus plus spécifique sur ce qu
on a par exemple vu de dans d'autres
pays européens comme l'utilisation de
toxic de façon un peu aigulin l'alcool
par exemple
et puis des questions plus de recherches
autour de la migraine et le
fonctionnement vasculaire cérébral et
puis des questions autour des maladies
infectieuses et notamment certaines
maladies sexuellement ma sexuellement
transmissibles dont certaines ont encore
des conséquences notamment sur la
fertilité féminine particulièrement
importante
l enquête va durer une dizaine d'années
j'ai cité de mots tout à l'heure
épidémiologique cohorte on peut
peut-être faire un peu de sémantique a
expliqué ce que ça signifie
épidémiologique et cohortes alors
cohorte terme n'est pas le terme vient
des armées romaines
il est particulièrement va
particulièrement dans le contexte l'idée
c'est simplement qu'on va suivre pendant
de nombreuses années plusieurs disent au
moins et bien un grand nombre
d'étudiants
alors quand on dit on va suivre jeu on
va leur demander de participer en fait
c'est une aventure à laquelle on veut
non pas les espionner en permanence n'a
évidemment pas on va leur demander de
participer de s'impliquer dans la
dynamique de cette recherche
et comme toute recherche qui il y adeux
laventure des choses à découvrir
on va leur demander de participer au
fond n'est pas si loin que ça du comité
community oui search qui est un
mouvement un peu un peu nouveau donc
voilà c'est quelque chose où on va
essayer de partager avec eux d'ailleurs
riechers et
le jeu partage et c'est plutôt tendance
en plus voilà pour essayer de les
inciter à venir je crois je crois que
c'est tendance et un peut-être ce qui
est sûr c'est que le constat et si on a
pris cette initiative qui est soutenue
par les investissements d'avenir quand
même et donc de l'investissement les
appels d'offres qu'il y avait il ya deux
ans dans la recherche beaucoup d'argent
avait été mis là dedans
si on april 6 si nous nous sommes
engagés dans cette aventure c'est qu'on
a fait le diagnostic au fond il y avait
pas beaucoup de chose de connu
concernant les étudiants leur santé et
puis aussi c'est à ce moment là que
certaines pathologies peuvent prendre
leurs sources entre guillemets c'est à
dire et donc ça c'est des choses que
nous allons investir vous parler du
financement tout à l'heure on peut
peut-être faire une parenthèse justement
ce sont quoi les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques aussi qu'ils participent
qui financent d'où vient cet argent
non non les le premier soutien que nous
avons obtenus et ta est un soutien
public c'est à dire que nous avons
répondu à un appel d'offres qui était
l'appel d'offres corps temps des
investissements d'avenir il y a deux ans
et le projet a été évaluée par un comité
scientifique international est
particulièrement bien l'évaluer enfin
suffisamment bien l'évaluer pour être
retenu voilà donc nous avons de l'argent
public pour pouvoir démarrer le projet
c'est bien évidemment pas suffisant et
nous sommes nous allons essayer de
trouver des partenaires là vous lancer
le dispositif
vous n'avez pas entièrement financés non
pas sur dix ans non mais c'est comme ça
tout le temps aux recherches et à dire
qu'on a une idée on pense qu'elle est
bonne on essaie de la faire soutenir par
des partenaires puis mais ça pourrait
s'arrêter si vous ne trouvez pas les
fonds encore comme tout projet de
recherche choisis comme tout projet de
recherche
il est pas différent celui là dans ce
sens de tout autre en place en
partenariat avec l'université de
bordeaux aussi alors c'est versailles
saint quentin sera notre université
alors c'est une bonne question c'est en
fait les deux partenaires
qui se sont associés pour prendre cette
initiative sont l'université de bordeaux
et l'université de versailles
d'abord parce qu'il faut bien commencer
et aussi parce que ce projet est piloté
par un collègue et ami qui est
professeur à bordeaux et je suis
professeur à versailles et on se lance
pas dans cette aventure en multipliant
les complications
il faut aller là où c'est facile tout de
même enfin parce que la marque tueur est
en elle même classe à sont les bases non
plus imaginer ça s'ouvre à d'autres je
crois qu'on ne pourra pas en faire
l'économie par le fait même que on
utilise les nouvelles technologies de la
communication et de l'information et que
utilisant toutes les possibilités
d'internet
eh bien on peut évidemment pas se
limiter à des populations des étudiants
qui serait uniquement sur deux
universités il y a nous sommes
d'ailleurs déjà sollicité par des
universités du sud de la france pour
rejoindre l'initiative que nous avons
pris les étudiants prend-il soin de leur
santé vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
ce n'est pas toujours évident nous ça
nous avait leur poser la question pour
avoir quelques témoignages tout
simplement micro trottoir j'essaie de
faire un footing quand je peux et puis
j'essaie de d'acheter des produits en
fait et légumes les fruits les légumes
les choses comme ça mais ça est quand
même un inconvénient puisque du coup
c'est assez cher pour les supermarchés
et vu que je suivis tout seul ben voilà
de suite le budget vous filles
commencent à augmenter
je ne fais pas attention à mon
alimentation mais je devrais je penserai
chez beaucoup des sports j'ai mal géré
pas et qui plaît enfin j'ai vite des fat
ou skip est très nuisible la santé voire
au monde habitent souvent loin on
apprend des trucs à manger tout ça donc
on mange pas forcément correctement
j'avoue que là l'équilibré les cinq
fruits et légumes par jour c'est
impossible
oui on mange mal mais mais je suis pas
sûr que ça quelque chose à quoi que ce
soit à voir avec le fait qu'on soit
fauché c'est plutôt que
quand on peut manger ce qu'on veut
manger des cochonneries témoignages
plutôt fenêtre en france' dernière
étudiants peut-être c'est marrant parce
que quand on parle santé et quand on
parle soins quand on parle de s'occuper
de soi ou pour sa nourriture en premier
pour les alliances et c'est
effectivement ce que j'observais dans le
reportage qui est assez intéressant
de ce point de vue évidemment que la
question de l'alimentation une question
qui survient assez immédiatement en fait
pour tout vous dire avant de démarrer de
rentrer dans la phase opérationnelle
nous avons eu beaucoup de discussion
avec des étudiants des discussions
individuelles et des discussions
collectives et alors l'alimentation
évidemment est un est une question qui
apparaît mais au fond on s'aperçoit
aussi que peut-être que pour eux mêmes
leur santé ou la santé
ce quelque chose d'un peu anecdotique
comme je disais tout à l'heure par
contre nombre d'entre eux parfois
s'interroge sur les difficultés que
certains de leurs amis peuvent avoir et
on voit bien que quand on discute un peu
en profondeur bas parfois il sort
effectivement ces questions notamment
les questions d'ordre psychologique
sorte assez fréquemment
et c'est des questions qui sont
particulièrement importantes aussi le
dispositif l'enquète ça et cher qui a
débuté donc toujours trouve toujours
tout juste pardon portera sur cinq
thématiques les migraines les infections
sexuellement transmissibles la
maturation du cerveau la santé mentale
les conduites à risque également les
étudiants vont tous déclaré que vous
allez vérifier ça aussi alors il ya deux
niveaux dans denrées cher il ya un
premier niveau où on va demander
régulièrement tous les ans aux étudiants
de répondre à des questionnaires et donc
la basse et ça va être simplement
sur les déclarations qu'ils feront des
questionnaires pourront évoluer parfois
on pour aller solliciter un petit peu
plus dès que des questionnaires de
taille
de taille très raisonnable une demi
heure un peu plus peut-être mais jamais
au-delà
et puis par par ailleurs au sein de la
chaire nous allons en proposer à
certains à ce qu'ils le voudront et bien
de s'investir dans des projets de
recherche plus spécifiques et et là
évidemment ça lors de mon bras un peu
plus d'investissement pour participer
comme d'autres participent dans d'autres
recherches ailleurs il gagne quoi ces
étudiants qui ont participé
alors ce qu'ils y gagnent ce qu'ils
eagles qui sera forcément vous est
proposé mais la question a déjà été
posée et c'est un obstacle que nous ne
sous-estimons pas ce qu'ils y gagnent
déjà c'est de participer à une aventure
à lormont est restée faible peut-être
n'est peut-être pas tant que ça et puis
ce qu'ils vont y gagner aussi c'est
probablement des réponses à leurs
questions
si vous avez regardé le site est cher
point fr il y a déjà une animation
autour de ça autour de récits de santé
de réponses à des questions nous allons
animer tout ça c'est à dire ce qu'ils
peuvent y gagner c'est de trouver des
informations qu'ils répondent de leurs
préoccupations
et puis aussi nous allons organiser
l'animation de la cohorte enfin de la
deûle aventure et bien nous organisons
des événements
probablement que sur versailles on est à
l'étude pour essayer de trouver des
partenaires avec lesquels on pourrait
organiser des événements soit musicaux
soit les spectacles enfin voilà toute
une dynamique qui est plutôt une
dynamique sur le partage encore une fois
alors peut-être c'est un pari mais voilà
et puis enfin quand on leur demande
droit de participer ou de faire des
choses un peu plus qui leur demandent
plus d'investissements ou plus de même
que ce soit en terme de temps on met
aussi un terme de
recherche biomédicale faire des
prélèvements l'aïd est certainement pas
exclu que certains étudiants puissent
entre être indemnisé une toute dernière
question très rapidement oui non ce sera
confidentielle ah oui et non seulement
c'est confidentiel mais en plus il y a
les accords des autorités ou des
instances qui font très attention à
cette question de l'anonymat notamment
de la cnil merci didier guillemot
professeur d'épidémiologie université de
versailles saint quentin projet ishare
qui est donc lancée 38 mille étudiants
qui vont participer le recrutement va
s'étaler sur cinq ans et pour
l'université de versailles saint quentin
ce sera à partir de la rentrée pour les
étudiants qui veulent se manifester y
participer merci à vous et puis il ya ce
site internet bien sûr qui s'est
affichée pour avoir encore plus
d'information merci